اهلا بكم مشاهدينا مستمرون معكم في هذا
اليوم الخاص بالاحتفال بالعيد راشين
للعربيه ولكن وكالمعتاد يوميا نبدا بابرز
عناوين هذه النشره
الولايات المتحده تفرض عقوبات جديده على
روسيا تشمل مسؤولين قضائيين
المعارضه التركيه تخفق في الاتفاق على
مرشح واحد لمواجهه اردوغان وتقترب من
خساره الجبهه الموحده
وفي انفراد جديد للعربيه تقرير خاص حول
اموال دون رقيب تجد طريقها الى عائلات
داعش في مخيم الهول وتوفر شريان حياه
للتنظيم
العربيه في عيدها العشرين الاكبر حضورا
على مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي
مستمرون معكم في هذه التغطيه الخاصه بعيد
العربيه العشرين ولكن نبدا معكم كما نبدا
دائما بابرز اخبار اليوم
فرضت الولايات المتحده عقوبات على سته
مواطنين روس بمن فيهم نائب وزير العدل
وقضاه وموظفوا لجنه التحقيق وحسب بيان
الخزانه الامريكيه فان العقوبات جاءت
لمسؤوليه هؤلاء عن سجن معارض موصي انتقد
غزو اوكرانيا ويتمنع العقوبات الجديده
هؤلاء المسؤولين الروس من الوصول الى
حسابات بنكيه امريكيه ومؤسسات ماليه اخرى
وايضا تشمل حضرا على التاشيرات
ذكر صحيفه بروتو ان الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن خلال زيارته لبولندا في فبراير
الماضي ابلغ دول بوخارسه التسعه ان واشنطن
لا تسعى لتغيير القياده في روسيا وذكر
صحيفه بلوتو نقلا عن مصادر ان بايدن قال
ان الهدف من الوضع في اوكرانيا ليس تغيير
السلطه في روسيا وتضيف الصحيفه ايضا ان
بايدن بعد زياره كياب وفي اجتماع مغلق
بوارسو اضطر بايدن الى ارسال تذكير الى
دول بوخارست التاسع الهدف من الوضع في
اوكرانيا لم يكن انهاء نظام بوتين هكذا
قال بايدن
اكد رئيس وزراء اوكرانيا ان جيش بلاده
يتبع معايير النيتو في القتال وسيستخدموا
اسلحته واكد ان وجود كيا في الناتو امر
حقيقي بحكم الامر الواقع نعم
الابواب المفتوحه ليست كافيه بالنسبه لنا
اوكرانيا تسمع هذه الجمل منذ سنوات نريد
ونتوقع قرارات حاسمه من حلفائنا جيشنا
يقاتل باستخدام معدات الناتو وقواتنا
المسلحه تعمل بمعايير الناتو وجودنا في
الناتو امر واقع
اكد سفير اوكرانيا لدى المانيا اوليكسيما
كيف بان كييف تناقش مع حلفائها احتياجاتها
في حربها مع روسيا بطريقه دقيقه للغايه
مشيرا الى ان وزاره الدفاع الاوكرانيه لم
تطلب بعد نوعا معينا من الطائرات من
المانيا
بطريقه دقيقه للغايه وغنيه بالمحتوى حتى
هذه اللحظه لم اتلقى اي طلب من وزاره
دفاعنا لنوع معين من الطائرات المتوفره في
المانيا اعلم ان مثل هذه المناقشات تجري
مع دول اخرى لكن مثل هذه المحادثات لا
تحدث عبر تويتر ولكن خلف الابواب المغلقه
الى اوكرانيا
بولندا سيكون دخولا مباشرا للحلف في الحرب
ضد روسيا واكد نائب رئيس مجلس الامن
الروسي انه سيتعين اعتبار كل من يقرر
توريد او صيانه هذه المعدات او وسائل
التدمير الى جانب المرتزقه والمدربين
الاجانب اكد انه سيتم اعتبارهم اهدافا
مشروعه على حد وصفه
اعلنت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه ان صيغه
السلام التي قدمها الرئيس الاوكراني لا
تهدف في الواقع الى تسويه سلميه للصراع
واضافت الخارجيه في بيان بان زليسكي يواصل
الترويج لما يسمى بصيغته للسلام والتي في
الواقع لا تهدف الى احلال السلام ولكن الى
تشكيل تحالف معاد لروسيا على حد وصف
البيان
ميدانيا اكد مؤسس فاجنر ان القوات الروسيه
حاصرت عمليا مدينه بخموت بالكامل لافتا
الى امتلاك القوات الاوكرانيه لطريق خروج
واحد من المدينه وفق تعبيره ودعم مؤسس
فاجنر الرئيس الاوكراني برودميرزنسكي الى
سحب قوته من المدينه التي تعد الجبهه
الاكثر اشتعالا منذ اشهر
سبعه اشهر من القتال الدموي في ضخمه
الاوكرانيه تتجه نحو الحسم لصالح روسيا في
الايام الاخيره تعرض طريق الامداد الوحيد
لقصف روسي كثيف لتزيد صعوبه الحصار على
المدينه
الروسيه التي تقاتل في المدينه منذ اشهر
اعلنت عن حصار المدينه تماما بعد التقدم
الذي احرزته في الاسابيع الاخيره شمال
وجنوبي المدينه طريق وحيد هو الذي بقي
منفذا باتجاه الغرب مؤديا الى مدينه
تشاسيفيار
رساله جاءت على لسان مؤسسها الذي خطب
الرئيسكي مطالبا اياه باستغلال الوقت
واخراج من تبقى من المدينه ابراج
حاصله وحدات فاجنر عمليا مدينه باخموت ولم
يتبقى منها سوى طريق واحد اذا كنا نقاتل
في وقت سابق ضد الجيش المحترف فاننا نرى
الان بشكل متزايد كبار السن والاطفال انهم
يقاتلون لكن الوقت المتوقع في بخموت قصير
جدا لا يتجاوز يوما او يومين لمنحهم فرصه
لمغادره المدينه
من طرفي الصراع الدموي في ضخمه يدعي يان
الحق خسائر فادحه بالطرف الاخر انهم لا
ياخذون في الحسبان خسائرهم في محاوله
الاستيلاء على المدينه بالهجوم تتمثل مهمه
قواتنا في بخمط في الحاق اكبر عدد ممكن من
الخسائر بالعدو
القوات المدافعه عن المدينه تصر على
الصمود في الدفاع معترفه بصعوبه الوضع في
الميدان بالتزامن مع سحب بعض الوحدات
العسكريه الاوكرانيه من مناطق سيطرتك
معركه باخموتيلا باتت تجسد الصمود
الاوكراني تتجه نحو الحسم الا ان القتال
المستميت وسقوطها في يد القوات الروسيه لن
يكون تقدما استراتيجيا حقيقيا لروسيا بحسب
المحللين اذا عمر العربيه
نقلت مجله عن مسؤولين امريكيين واخرين في
الناتو قولهم ان موسكو وتهران تخططان
لبناء مصنع لطائرات مسيره في روسيا وحسب
المسؤولين الغربيين الذين نقلت عنهم
تنوي تزويده اهرام بمقاتلات ومروحيات
وانظمه الدفاع الجوي وقالت الصحيفه ان دعم
ايران لروسيا في اوكرانيا لن يقلب موازين
القوه لكنه سيرفع عدد الضحايا وان تزويد
روسيا لايران بانظمه الدفاع الجوي متطوره
مثل اس 300 او اس 400 سيساعدها على تعزيز
حمايه منشاتها النوويه من ضربات اسرائيليه
محتمله
وهنتابع مع حضراتكم هذه الصور المباشره من
اثينا لتظاهرات
احتجاجا على
الحادثه التي وقعت في صدام قطارين نجد
هناك عدد من المتظاهرين يقومون باحراق هذه
المعدات على ما يبدو هذا احتجاجا على
الحادث الخاص بتصادم قطارين احدهما كان
للركاب والاخر للمسافرين واستقال على اثره
وزير النقل هناك هذه الحادثه اثار
التساؤلات كبيره للغايه وجرى التحقيق مع
عدد كبير من المسؤولين وايقاف الشركات
ايضا المشغله لتلك القطارات
هذه مواجهات نشاهد صور لها على الهواء
مباشره مواجهات ما بين الشرطه ومتظاهرين
في اثنا هذه الحرائق مشتعله بفعل قيام
البعض باحراق هذه الاطارات او هذه المعدات
على ما يلي
[موسيقى]
نقش وزير الدفاع الاسرائيلي مع رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه التهديد
الايراني على اسرائيل والعالم وحسب بيان
اسرائيليه فقد اكد وزير الدفاع ياقوف
جالنت على اهميه التعاون الدولي لمنع
ايران من حيازه سلاح النووي
يتضمن ذلك مع وصول المدير العام للوكاله
الدوليه للطاقه الدوليه رافاييل الروسي
الى طهران لاجراء مناقشات بشان برنامج
ايران نووي وذلك بعد اكتشاف الجزيئات من
اليورينيوم المخصب بمستوى قريب من صنع
قنبله نوويه والتقى الروسي خلال زيارته
مدير منظمه الطاقه الذريه الايرانيه محمد
اسلامي كما كان من المقرر ان يلتقي
مسؤولين ايرانيين اخرين بمن فيهم الرئيس
ابراهيم رئيسي
في ايران ايضا ولكن في شان اخر خرج
محتاجون بالروش عقب صلاه الجمعه في مظاهره
حاشده رافعين لافتات تحمل شعار الموت
للديكتاتور وللحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
الله اكبر الله اكبر
زعم رئيس الايراني ابراهيم رئيسي ان من
وصفهم باعداء طهران هم منسعوا لاشعه
التوتر والظهر بين الطلاب واولياء وامورهم
على خلفيه قضيه تسمم الطالبات وقال رئيس
الايراني انه وجه وزيري الداخليه والامن
بمتابعه قضايا تسمم في المدارس وتقديم
تقرير كامل عن الموضوع وكان التقارير اكدت
التعرض مئات الطالبات للتسمم في جميع
انحاء البلاد في وقت حضرت فيه يونيسيف من
هذه الحادثه وتاثيرها على تعليم الفتيات
ايران
هزار ارض خصبه لابتلاع اعذار النظام
الايراني وامتصاص اخطائه تحولت لها دول
الغرب فهناك يرمي انتهاكاته بمجالاتها
المتعدده ليزعم وقوف من يصفهم بالاعداء
خلف كل ما يجري في بلاده
فصول قمع الاحتجاجات لم تنتهي بعد ليتسرب
عبرها غاز تسبب بتسمم طالبات في المدارس
هذه ايضا تهمه الصقها بطريقه ما الرئيس
الايراني ابراهيم رئيس بالغرب الذي يسعى
وفق تعبيره لاشاعه التوتر والذعر بين
الطلاب واولياء امورهم واثاره الاضطرابات
في ايران
معاناه الفتيات الايرانيات وسلبهن حق
التعليم بات موضع قلق دول غربيه عده بينها
الولايات المتحده والمانيا فهجمات السم
الخفيف فسرها السياسيون على انها استهداف
من قبل الجماعات المتشدده المعارضه لتعليم
الفتيات
يجب ان تتمكن الفتيات من الذهاب الى
المدرسه بلا خوف هذا حقهن الانساني ببساطه
يجب التحقيق بشكل كامل في كل الحالات
حالات تسمم متوسطه لمئات الفتيات اعلنت
عنها وزاره الصحه الايرانيه خلال الاشهر
القليله الماضيه وبين السوق الاتهامات
والقاء اللوم وجه رئيس وزير الداخليه
والامن بمتابعه قضايا التسمم في المدارس
فيما كلف رئيس مجلس الشورى محمد باقر
قليباث اربعه لجان برلمانيه بالتحقيق
واكتشاف اسباب الحوادث وقد تم القاء القبض
على ثلاثه اشخاص اشتبه بتورطهم في القضيه
لكن الاجهزه الام نفت اكتشافها لماده سامه
قد تكون السبب في تسمم الطلبه
الخارجيه السعوديه عن السنكار المملكه
العربيه السعوديه شديد لتصريحات المتطرفه
التي ادلى بها احد مسؤول الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي من خلال مطالبته بمحو قريه
حواره الفلسطينيه واكدت الخارجيه السعوديه
رفض المملكه التام لهذه التصريحات
العنصريه مشدده على مطالبتها للمجتمع
الدولي بالاطلاع بالمسؤوليته لرفع هذه
الممارسه المشينه ووقف التصعيد وتوفير
الحمايه اللازمه للمدنيين
هذا وداع للاتحاد الاوروبي حكومه اسرائيل
الى التبرا من تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي التي دعا بها الى محو بلده
حواره الفلسطينيه جنوب نابلس بعد الاحداث
الاخيره واكد للتحاضر الاوروبي ان تصريحات
الوزير الاسرائيلي غير مقبوله ولا يمكن
التسامح معها ووجه لاتحاد الاوروبي تمسكه
بمبادئ شرعيه الدوليه لحل النزاع
الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني
هذا واجرى ممثل لاتحاد الاوروبي في فلسطين
زياره تفقديه الى بلده حواره في نابلس
وذلك في اعقب تعرضها لسلسله من الهجمات
الدبلوماسيه الاوروبي الذي وصل الى الضفه
الغربيه على راسي وفد كبير من سفراء
ودبلوماسيين اوروبيين شدد على تضامنه مع
الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا اكبر وفد دبلوماسي على الاطلاق على
مستوى رؤساء البعثات زار اي مكان في
فلسطين هذه علامه في حد ذاتها على التضامن
والوقوف معكم جنبا الى جنبك
ونستمر مع حضراتكم في هذه النشره من قناه
العربيه
بعد هذا الفاصل وننتقل مع حضراتكم الى هذه
الصور الخاصه باستقبال الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن للمستشار الالماني في البيت الابيض
وهي الزياره الثانيه الى واشنطن
بينما تقوم روسيا بتجميع قواتها لشن حربها
على اوكرانيا كان لابد
لنا ان نستجيب وساويه
او فينا بوعدنا شكرا لكم على وقفتكم شكل
الامر فارقا كبيرا
وسويا
او فينا بالوعد
وقمنا بتقديم الدعم العسكري
وخلف الدعم العسكري هناك الدعم المعنوي
الذي قدم لاوكرانيا
فقد احدث فارقا كبيرا
حتى على مستوى داخل البلاد من حيث الانفاق
الدفاعي
وكنا قد عملنا
عفويا على
تزويد اوكرانيا
بالمساعدات العسكريه الضروريه من حيث
الاسلحه الدفاعيه والدبابات وقد كذلك
عملنا على الوفاء بمتطلبات اوكرانيا
الاساسيه مثل الغذاء
وغيرهم من المعونات الطبيه او استمرينا في
فرض الضغوط على بوتين
وكحلفاء في النيتو فاننا نجعل هذا الحلف
اكثر قوه وقدره ولعلكم سمعتوني قل انني
قلت من قبل عندما تحدثت الى بوتين قبل
بضعه اشهر قلت له
بان ان
حلف النيتو ماض في عزيمته ووحدته اكثر من
اي وقت مضى في كافه انحاء اوروبا هذا ما
كنا قد تحدثنا به في السنه الماضيه شكرا
على استضافته مره اخرى
ودعني اقول
انها سنه
مهمه بسبب المخاطر مخاطر الحرب التي تاتي
من روسيا في اوكرانيا لذا من الضروره ان
نعمل معا
وان نقدم الدعم الممكن والعمليه لاوكرانيا
وفي هذه الاوقات ارى من الضروره بان نبعث
برساله باننا مستمرون في نفس المسار مهما
استغرق الامر من وقت
واننا لن نغير موقفنا البته في دعم
اوكرانيا وانني اثمن
صراحه حسن التعاون فيما بيننا وبين
الولايات المتحده والمانيا واوروبا فهذه
العلاقه وشراكه تعد في افضل احوالها اليوم
وانا سعيد لاكون هنا للتحدث معك بمزيد من
التفصيل في هذا العمل
[موسيقى]
تبعنا مع حضراتكم كلمه المستشار الالماني
في البيت الابيض خلال اجتماعه مع الرئيس
الامريكي جو بايدن وهي الزياره الثانيه
للمستشار الالماني حيث زار واشنطن في
فبراير 2022 وهذه الزياره كانت محط اهتمام
كبير من قبل الكرملين كان الكريم ايضا حذر
من ان يكون هناك دعم جديد من الاسلحه
المتطوره الى اوكرانيا مؤكدا ان هذا الامر
سيؤدي الى اطاله امد الصراع في اوكرانيا
كانت هذه المخاوف التي ابداها الكريم
للنعود مره اخرى لمتابعه هذا اللقاء بين
شولتيز وبايدن
نتابع هذا اللقاء ونتابع تفاصيله بعد قليل
ايضا في خدمتنا الاخباريه ولكن كان هذا هو
العنوان الرئيسي الذي حمل عنوانا واحدا
وهو استمرار الجانبين في دعم اوكرانيا
بشكل كبير بالاسلحه نواصل مع حضراتكم
تقديم هذه النشره اعلنت زعيم حزب الخير
المعارض التركي ميرال اكشن عن رفض حزبها
ترشيح زعيم المعارضه ورئيس حزب الشعب
الجمهوري كمال اوغلو في الانتخابات
الرئاسيه القادمه واوضحت اكشنار ان خمسه
زعماء من قاده احزاب الطاوله السداسيه
قرره ترشيحك
رغم كل المؤشرات التي تؤكد تقدم رئيس
بلديه اسطنبول اكرم امام اوغلو ورئيس
بلديه انقره منصور يافش في استطلاعات
الراي وامكانيه فوزهما بالانتخابات
الرئاسيه مؤكده ان حزبها لن يرضخ لضغوط
الطويله السداسيه بترشيحك
في المرحله الحاليه اضطر الحزب الصالح الى
الفرد واجبر على الاختيار بين الموت
والملاريا تماما كما حدث للامه التركيه
لسنوات وبالطبع لن يرضخ الحزب الصالح الى
هذا كحزب الواي اي اعربنا عن راينا في
ترشيح اسمي اولئك الذين سمعناهم كثيرا في
الشوارع والمتاجر والساحات العامه لاكثر
من ثلاث سنوات تلك التي شهدناها في كل
مكان تقريبا اظهرتها امتنا بشده المحسوبيه
واولئك الذين رايناهم في جميع الاستطلاعات
العامه فازوا بفارق كبير على السيد
اردوغان لفتره طويله هذان الاسمان هما
عمده مدينه انقره السيد منصور يافاس وعمده
مدينه اسطنبول السيد اكرم امام اوغلو
اعلنت الحكومه السويسريه تخفيف العقوبات
المفروضه على سوريا منذ عام 2011 من اجل
تسهيل عمل المنظمات الانسانيه التي تقدم
المساعده لمنكوب الزلزال وجاء في بيان
الحكومه السويسريه ان هذه الخطوه تهدف الى
تسهيل اقامه علاقات تجاريه ضروريه لعمل
المنظمات الانسانيه في سوريا ونوهت الى ان
المرسومه الحكومي بشان العقوبات ضد سوريا
يسمح لسلطات السويسريه ان تمنح المنظمات
الانسانيه العامله في سوريا الحق في
الخروج عن هذه القواعد عند اجراء
المعاملات الماليه اللازمه لدعم السكان
المدنيين
قتلت 2 من قوه سوريا الديمقراطيه في شمال
محافظه الرقه اثر قصف المدفعيه التركيه
على المنطقه وفقا لوكاله انباء الفرات
الجيش التركي استخدم المدافع ثقيله وقذائف
الهاون انطلاقا من مناطق سيطره فصائل
المعارضه ملحقا الضرر بعدد من المنازل دون
معلومات عن الاصابات بين المدنيين
اعلنت القياده المركزيه الامريكيه عن
تنفيذها مع شركاء اخرين 48 عمليه ضد عناصر
تنظيم داعش في العراق وسوريا الشهر الماضي
واوضحت القياده ان هذه العمليات اسفرت عن
مقتل 22 عنصرا من التنظيم واعتقالي 25
اخرين ووصفت العمليات ضد داعش بالمهمه
لمنع التنظيم من استعاده قدرته في المنطقه
ومهاجمه الحلفاء والمصالح الامريكيه في
الخارج
بان اعلن الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد انه ان
الاوان لمحاسبه المتربصين بالشعب حسب وصفه
صعيد قال ان الاتحاد التونسي للشغل له
الحريه لتنظيم المظاهرات لكن ليس في دعوه
الاجانب للمشاركه فيها وان ذلك امر غير
مقبول مضيفا ان هناك من يريد الافلات من
المحاسبه
هناك من يريد ان يبدو بعض الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبول على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
لتكن معاملاتهم معهم كمؤسسات
ولكن تونس ليست ضيعه او بستانا
عبر متظاهرون في جمهوريه الكونغو
الديمقراطيه عن رفضهم لزياره الرئيس
الفرنسي لبلادهم وكانت هذه التظاهرات جزءا
من سلسله احتجاجات بدات هذا الاسبوع قبل
وصول مكرمه الى المحطه الاخيره من جوله في
وسط افريقيا التي سعى من خلالها الى الناي
بنفسه عن الماضي الاستعماري لفرنسا
هذا وتجاهل رئيس الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون
هذه التظاهرات واكد انه مهتم بالمساعده في
وقف اطلاق النار بين الحكومه والقوات
المتمرده
لقد امضينا وقتا طويلا مع رئيس جمهوريه
الكونغو الديمقراطيه لمناقشه الوضع في شرق
البلاد اريد حقا ان احيي الدوره الذي يقوم
به ضمن اليه الاشراف والمراقبه ومساعي
المفاوضات الجاريه التي تهدف لوقف اطلاق
النار قمنا باجراء نقاش معمق يغذي الامال
المشروع في تحقيق نتائج ملموسه في الايام
المقبله للتوصل الى وقف للتصعيد وتحقيق
السلام والاستقرار في البلاد
كانت هذه اهم الاخبار عربيه ودوليا
واقليميا فاصل قصير نتابع بعده النشره
ولكن بتغطيه خاصه لعيد العربيه العشرين
ابقوا معنا
العربيه ليست شاشه فقط بل شبكه من المنصات
ووسائل التواصل الاجتماعي التي تغطي كافه
اهتماماتكم بالخبر لذلك كان حضور العربيه
القوي على مختلف منصات التواصل الاجتماعي
بمحتوى ينقل الشاشه الى هواتفكم وينجز لكم
مواد خاصه اخرى لاهتمامات قد تغيب عن
الشاشه احيانا
[موسيقى]
اوكرانيا لكن
ومعنا اليوم العناصر الفعليه التي تعمل في
هذا المحتوى وتحقق نتائج نفخر بها جميعا
معنا في الاستوديو الزميل محمد الحكواتي
مدير العمليات التقنيه في قناه العربيه
مرحبا بك محمد في هذه التغطيه وكل عام
وانت بخير ايضا ينضم الينا من الاستوديو
ايضا الزميل لويس بشاره منتج محتوى منصه
اكثر وهي منافقه جديده للعربيه تتميز ايضا
شكرا لك لوجودك معنا ومن رام الله ايضا
الزميل امجد سمحان مدير قسم التواصل
الاجتماعي في قناه العربيه مرحبا بك امجد
وانت دايما بعد قريب اليوم تبدو بعض
المسافات البعيده قليلا ولكن طاقه قريبا
دائما امجد محمد هناك دائما تساؤلات حول
التواصل الاجتماعي وسائل التواصل
الاجتماعي والى اي مدى يمكن ان تحل بالفعل
محل الشاشات نحن في العربيه حريصون كل
الحرص على ان يكون لنا تواجد قوي على هذه
المنصات بشكل مختلف كيف هي الارقام صحيح
هلا نحن العربيه طبعا غير القناه موجود
عنا الموقع الموقع متوفر باربع لغات
طبعا على موقعنا القراءات بشكل شهري
بتتراوح بين 20 مليون زائر وعدد القراءات
تتجاوز 60 مليون بشكل شهري بالنسبه لارقام
السوشيال ميديا امجد ممكن يفيدنا اكثر
بالارقام على المنصات السوشيال ميديا ماذا
عن السوشيال ميديا امجد وارقام متابعات
العربيه انت دائما ما تاخذنا في جلسات
واجتماعات وتعرض علينا الارقام كيف تبدو
الارقام امجد
حقيقه رشا بدايه كل عام وانتم بخير كل عام
وجميع الزملاء في العربيه بخير في هذا
الاحتفال يعني عشرين عام من التميز ختمتها
العربيه في هذه السنه بصراحه ارقام
ملياريه على كافه المنصات نحن اليوم نتحدث
عن اكثر من مليار مشاهده على منصات
العربيه المختلفه
نتحدث عن اكثر من 220 حساب في هذه اللحظه
وفي كل لحظه عم يفتح عنا حسابات جديده نحن
لا نقول فقط ان العربيه هي الشاشه التي
يشاهدها المتابع وانما هي عباره عن شبكه
كبيره وضخمه من المنصات المختلفه التي
تقدم المحتوى باشكاله المختلفه سواء كان
المحتوى القادم من شاشه العربيه او
المحتوى المنتج خصيصا من خلال فرق
السوشيال ميديا
او حتى المحتوى الذي يخاطب الدول العربيه
بصفحات مخصصه لهذه الدول ارقام العربيه
كبيره جدا وهي في ازدياد وقوه العربيه
تاتي دائما من خلال هذه الارقام التي تعكس
صراحه مدى ثقه الجمهور بالعربيه ومدى
اهتمامه بالمحتوى الذي يقدم على منصات
العربيه واللي هو بيعكس سياسه العربيه
المهنيه والحرفيه والى اخره عندما نتحدث
رشا عن ارقام منصات التواصل المختلفه على
سبيل المثال دعينا ننتقل مثلا لاخر تغطيه
تغطيه زلزال تركيا سوريا خلال هذه الفتره
العربيه حققت مليار و600 مليون مشاهده
وهذا الرقم قياسي جدا يعني تتحدثين عن
مليار و600 مليون مشاهده على ما نشهر من
محتوى على مختلف منصاتنا عندما نتحدث عن
220 حساب للعربيه نتحدث عن كميه هائله من
الحسابات التي تضخ باستمرار مثلا
نحن ننشر سنويا اكثر من مليون ونصف
المليون منشور ايضا هذا الرقم كثير ضخم
وبالتالي كل ما يقدم من محتوى على منصات
التواصل هو في الاساس وما ياتي من خلاله
من ارقام هو في الاساس يعكس الرساله التي
انشات من اجلها العربيه وهي ايصال
المعلومه وايصال الخبر وايصال الحقيقه
ونقل المعرفه للجمهور العربي اينما تواصل
عندما نتحدث عن المحتوى مثلا نتحدث عن
اشكال مختلفه من المحتوى هناك المحتوى
الذي ياتي من الشاشه كانت استراتيجيه
العربيه ان تقوم بنقل الشاشه مباشره الى
هاتف المتابع اين موجب فصرنا نقوم باقتطاع
كليبات صغيره من ما ينشر او مما يبث على
منصاتنا سواء على نشرات الاخبار او
البرامج وكل ما ينتج على الشاشه من محتوى
ونقوم باقتطاع كليبات صغيره حتى نستطيع
نوصل للمشاهد العربي المعلومه في الوقت
القياسي والسريع وبالوقت المختصر في الوقت
ذاته الشاشه دائما تزدحم بالاخبار
والملفات واحيانا هناك بعض المواضيع التي
لا يمكن للشاشه ان تغطيها لهذا السبب او
لذاك
لذلك قمنا بانشاء منتجات او محتوى مخصص
فقط السوشيال ميديا يعني ما بنشوفه على
الشاشه هذا المحتوى يلبي رغبات الجمهور
الواسع والمتنوع والموجود يعني بفئات
عمريه وناطق مختلفه
في بعض الاماكن رشا الدول عفوا الدول
العربيه على سبيل المثال مثلا في مصر او
في الجزائر او في تونس او في فلسطين هناك
صفحات للعربيه والحدث نتحدث عن الشبكه
تتناول الاخبار المحليه لهذه الدول واللي
ايضا الشاشه ربما لا تستطيع ان تغطيها في
هذا الوقت اباك بسبب الانشغال والزحمه
الاخباريه الموجوده نعم
سنعود الى الارقام مره اخرى وساعطي لك نفس
عميق لترد على السؤال القادم دائما يعني
باستخدام النيران الصديقه او حتى باستخدام
بعض المنافسين يقولون من اين اتيتم بهذه
الارقام وما الذي يؤكد انها ارقام صحيحه
وتؤكد حقيقيه ساعطي لك نفس عميق لترد على
هذا السؤال واعود مره اخرى الى محمد محمد
نحن نتحدث عن واقع مختلف بالنسبه للصحافه
في العالم باكمله كيف تتعامل العربيه نجمع
هذا التطور المتلاحق والشديد تعلم ان هناك
صحف عالميه عريقه لسنوات طويله تواجه الان
ازمه في المحتوى وفي امكانيه وجود توزيعات
لها ومتابعين وما الى ذلك يعني احنا هلا
بالنسبه للعربيه مثل ما تفضل امجد احنا
المحتوى مش بس ننقل محتوى القناه بكون في
مواضيع مخصصه بناء على شو الاهتمامات يعني
توسع في مواضيع الرياضه والتوسع في مواضيع
المحليه في المواضيع الاقتصاديه بالاضافه
لهيك بيكون
محمد بالاضافه للسياسيه
فهي مثل نحكي مثل
تكون القناه بتنعكس للتعمق اكثر ممكن وقت
القناه ما بيسمح انه التعمق
بوقت اطول فبكون الموقع والسوشيال ميديا
هي بتعطي مساحه اكبر للمحرين وغرفه
بالاسهاب اكثر في الموضوع وعرضه
بالنسبه على الموقع احنا بنحاول نركز على
اهم شغلتين انه تكون سهوله وصول الموقع
وسرعه التحميل الصفحه وهذه من الناحيه
التقنيه لا احد يعني يعاني منها سهله
للغايه
نحن بالفتره الماضي اشتغلنا من المواكب
التكنولوجي بحيث تكون العربيه سباق مقارن
بكل المواقع الاخباريه العالميه بحيث تكون
بسموها سرعه تحميل الصفحه باسرع وقت
بالاضافه
الزميل استاذ ممدوح المهيني المدير عامله
قناه العربيه والحدث في حوار قريب للشرق
الاوسط قال ان الارقام تؤكد ان الجمهور
يشاهد المحتوى الجاد وليس كما يتوقع البعض
انه يشاهد بعض المحتويات من التافهه او
الغير مهمه هناك استناد الى ارقام اكبر
مثال
الحادث الزلزال قبل فتره
شاهدنا خلال فتره الزلزال بالساعات الاولى
ارتفاع عدد القراءات اربع اضعاف المتوسط
اللي بيجي على الموقع واستمرت هاي الفتره
لحد اليوم يعني لما يكون في خبر سياسي
كبير او حدث سياسي كبير بنلاحظ انه في
ارتفاع مهول بعدد القراءات على الموقع
بتتجاوز ضعفين والثلاث اضعاف في لحظات
معينه ونفس الشيء بتلاقي لما يكون في
تغطيه مباشره للعربيه على القناه ارتفاع
ملحوظ على البث المباشر على الموقع لانه
العربيه هي مشاهده يعني الطلعه على عشره
دول اللي عم تشاهد الموقع
حتلاقي السعوديه مصر الولايات المتحده
كندا المانيا الامارات الاردن لانه في
عالم مش سهل توصل للقناه عن طريق
التلفزيون التقليدي فبتلاقي بحاولوا
يوصلوا للتغطيه العربيه عن طريق الوسائل
البديله من هالموقع منها السوشيال ميديا
فعشان هيك بنلاقي انه انتشار العربيه مش
محدود بس منطقه الشرق الاوسط لا منتشر على
على مختلف الدول العالميه
طيب
عودتك فاصل طويل امجد لتفكر في سؤال جيدا
فيما يتعلق بارقام المشاهدات البعض يقول
دائما
لم اكن بحاجه لهذا النفس لانه صراحه
الموضوع ليس اختراعا كل هذه الارقام
بامكان اي شخص ان يتابعها ويراها لانها
اصلا موجوده يعني هناك برامج موجوده لدى
صانعي المحتوى وغيرهم تتيح لاي شخص ان
يعمل البحث الذي يريد ليعرف ان كانت هذه
الامور حقيقيه او لا مثلا على سبيل المثال
هناك موقع وهو احد اهم المواقع التي ترصد
مشاهدات صانعي المحتوى على مستوى العالم
هذا الموقع بامكان اي شخص ان يشترك فيه
ويعرف ان كانت ما نقوله هو ارقام حقيقيه
او لا الحقيقه لا هي ارقام موجوده وهي
مثبته بعده بمئات الطرق وهي تعكس كما قلت
رشا مدى ثقه واحترام الجمهور
لما يقدم من محتوى عبر منصات العربيه نقطه
اخرى اريد ان اشير اليها اطلاقا ليس كما
كان الحوار مع زميلنا محمد المحتوى الذي
يحصل المشاهدات بشكل عام هو المحتوى
الرزين والمحتوى الهادف والمحتوى المتين
وليس كما يشاع او يقال هنا او هناك بانه
المحتوى الذي التافه بين قوسين يعني
اطلاقا مش صحيح
القوه العربيه بالتحديد تاتي من هذه
النقطه كل المشاهدات العاليه والارقام
القياسيه التي حققت على منصات العربيه
كانت في تغطيات
سنعود الى هذه النقطه لانها مهمه للغايه
تعلم ان احيانا يتم اصدار بعض الاحكام
ويقولون ان الجمهور عايز كده والجمهور
بريء يعني نحن نبارا الجمهور الان من خلال
هذه المشاهدات هو
رشا الجمهور هو ذاته الجمهور الذي يشاهد
الشاشه هو الجمهور اللي موجود في المكان
ربما تختلف الاهتمامات من فئه عمريه الى
اخرى هذا لا يعكس او لا ينطبق اطلاق تماما
لا ينطبق على حاله هذه اطول مره اشاهد
فيها امجد يتحدث لم اكن اعرف انه يتحدثك
كثيرا ما هو احنا بندافع عن مضمون يا رب
عن مضمون يقدم عبر منصاتنا طيب اسمح لنا
امجد ان ينطم الينا ايضا الزميل لوس اب
بشعرها منتج محتوى منصه اكثر وهي ايضا
منصه جديده للعربيه مرحبا بك لويس لنعطي
فكره لمشاهدينا عن اكثر من اين اتت الفكره
ولماذا مساء الخير رشا مساء الخير
اكثر ببساطه كتير بحب اني اشرح للناس
الفكره لانه هي جميله جدا
ولدت من الشعار الاحب على قلب كل الناس
ومتابعي قناه العربيه ان تعرف اكثر
فاخذناها الاكثر وديناها لمساحات اكبر عبر
السوشيال ميديا وصنعنا منا عده منصات بتهم
الناس بتهم الجيل الجديد بطريقه شبابيه
منصه بتحاكي جوانب الحياه المختلفه من
السياحه من صحه التكنولوجي اشاهد المحتوى
الذي تقدمه
بشاره وهو المتعلق ببعض المعلومات الخاطئه
الجمهور عاده يعتمد على بعض المعلومات
الصحيه الخاطئه نحن في منصه اكثر نصحح هذه
المعلومات بشكل علمي صحيح هذا هاي نقطه
كتير مهمه وهذه من التحديات اللي يمكن
اللي يواجهت صناع المحتوى وخاصه اذا كنا
عم نمثل مؤسسه اعلاميه عريقه فلازم نلتزم
دائما بانه الاخبار تكون موثوقه في ظل فيض
من الاخبار ان كانت اخبار مغلوطه وان كانت
حتى اخبار مش كامله فهون بيجي دورنا كمنصه
انه ننقل المعلومه الصحيحه بكل المجال
الذي يتفاعل للجمهور معنا في هذه المنصه
الجديده اكثر يعني التفاعل نحن بلشنا بشهر
نوفمبر من السنه الماضيه 2022
التفاعل كان جميل جدا كبير جدا والناس
حقيقه عم بتح ب وعم بتشارك هذا المحتوى
طبعا التطلعات كتير كبيره والاهداف
المستقبليه عاليه جدا اكثر بدات بسبع
منصات ولكن نحن على الطريق ماشيين لحتى
تتوسع هذه المنصات وتشمل جوال
نعود الى امجد مره اخرى نحن جميعا كمزعين
دائما ما نخشى امجد يعني
لازم امجد يكون راضي عننا عشان المحتوى
بتاعنا يكون موجود امجد ماذا عن العلاقه
مع المنافسين امجد لاننا في النهايه نعيش
في عالم فيه تنافس شديد ليس فقط القنوات
تنافس بعضها ولكن ايضا السوشيال ميديا
تنافسنا في ما نقدمه من محتوى منافسه شرسه
وصعبه
لا شك رشا هناك عشرات المنافسين الذين
يقدمون محتوى لكن وهذا الشيء صراحه دائما
يدعونا الى المفخره العربيه يوجد بينها
وبين اقرب منافس مسافات صراحه خصوصا خلال
السنوات الثلاث الماضيه لانه استراتيجيه
العربيه قامت على انه احنا نوسع الانتشار
ونقوي المحتوى الموجود على منصات التواصل
يعني مثلا في عام 2022 حسب هذا الموقع
الذي اشرت اليه تيوبر لابس العربيه كانت
اكثر صانع محتوى اخباري على مستوى العالم
يحظى بعدد مشاهدات سنويه احنا كنا نتحدث
عن 14 مليار مشاهده حققتها منصات التواصل
في اكثر من مره تم تصنيف مواقع العربيه
على انها الاكثر متابعه ولاكثر مشاهده على
سبيل المثال العربيه كانت اول محطه توصل
عشره ملايين متابع على منصه يوتيوب حاليا
هي بين صانعي الاخبار هي الاولى من عدد
المتابعين نتحدث عن 12 مليون متابع على
فيسبوك كذلك الحال العربيه لديها اكثر من
30 مليون متابع ايضا على تيك توك
وبالمناسبه المنصه حديثه على صانعي
المحتوى العربي هي الاولى الان لدينا
حوالي
مليونير متابع ولدينا مشاهدات مليونيه
العربيه منتشره بك والحدث طبعا الشبكه
كلها منتشره بكثافه من خلال المنصات
العديده ومن خلال المحتوى المتنوع والشامل
والاخباري الذي يقدم الى الجمهور وبالتالي
هذا جعل العربيه امجد
او ستكون فكره جيده انه بالارقام
وبالارقام الموثوقه التي تحمل المصداقيه
وليس فقط كما يقال دائما بعض القنوات ليس
ان نتحدث عن قنوات بعينيها ولكن البعض
يقول نحن الاكثر نحن الاعلى نحن طيب فيما
يتعلق حكواتي الارقام موجوده يعني انت
اليوم رشا فيك تروحي مثلا على المنافسين
منافسا منافسا وتشوفي مثلا عدد المتابعين
كم متابعين العربيه كم متابع للاخرين
فبالتالي بالنسبه لانك
انك دائما صمت طيب حكواتي فيما يتعلق احنا
نتحدث عن العربيه عشرين سنه يا رشح طبعا
كل عام وانت بخير وكل زملاء والاعزاء بخير
وبسلام محمد هناك تساؤلات حول ايضا كيف
نتحدث مع الاخر اللغات التي يتم الاعتماد
عليها تمام هلا العربيه انطلق الموقع بال
وجدت الحاج لاطلاق الموقع بلغه باللغه
الانجليزيه للوصول الناطقين باللغه
الانجليزيه والمهتمين باخبار المنطقه وعم
بيبحثوا عن مصدر للاخبار من قلب المنطقه
توسعنا كمان بالموقع الفارسي والموقع
الاردني تمام غير توسع اللغات احنا عم
نتوسع على مختلف المنصات غير منصات
السوشيال ميديا العربيه مش بس هي موقع
موجود العربيه كتطبيق على الهواتف الذكيه
من اندرويد من ايفون موجوده على السمارت
واتشز موجوده على
على الابل تي في
وحتى على الاجهزه
وموجوده على الاجهزه المنزليه مثل اليكسا
اللي فيك بس بامر صوتي تحكي لانه اليكسا
شو اخبار اليوم بتلاقي العربيه بتحكي لها
ملخص اخبار اليوم واخر شيء
اطلقناه كان هو تطبيق العربيه على كار
بلاي بحيث انه تكون اذا حدا سيارته مهيئه
للكار بلاي او متوفر بتدعم الكارب بلاي
بمجرد انت شبكه التليفون على السياره
بتقدر تستمع موقعنا بالانجليزيه هذا
الموقع له اهميه كبيره وتساؤل كبير
بالنسبه
للمشاهدين والمتابعين من الخارج هلا
بالنسبه لانتشار موقع اللغه الانجليزيه
طبعا
من ناحيه القراءات
بالنسبه للمغتربين الموجودين في منطقه
الخليج في السعوديه في الامارات الغير
ناطقيه من اللغه العربيه طبعا احنا بنوجه
كل الاخبار بتكون موجهه لهم بالاضافه لهيك
في
المتلقي الغربي
بالولايات المتحده في اوروبا وبالاضافه
لهيك في الناطقين منلاحظ قراءات كثيره من
شرق اسيا ومن باكستان مع كل ذلك زميل محمد
الحكواتي مدير العاملات التقنيه في قناه
العربيه شكرا لك محمد وكل عام وانت بخير
والشكر لزملاء جميعا في القسم ايضا الشكر
لزميلي لويس بشاره منتج محتوى منصه اكثر
شكرا لك وشكرا ايضا لزميلنا امجد سمحان
مدير قسم مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في قناه
العربيه شكرا لك
منذ بدايه العربيه كان قدرها تغطيه موسعه
في مختلف بلدان العالم لاحداث لم ولن تنسى
جهود كبيره بدلها مراسل العربيه ولا
يزالون واحدون من هؤلاء زميلنا مراسل
العربيه في لندن مصطفى زارو مرحبا بك
مصطفى يعني احداث كثيره قمت بتغطيتها كنت
دائما عنوانا للتميز والمصداقيه والصابقه
بالخبر مصطفى مؤخرا غطت العربيه بشكل اشاد
به الجميع جنازه الملكه اليزابيث الثانيه
وهذا كان حدث تاريخي كبير كيف كانت اجواء
هذه التغطيه
مساء الخير رشا وكل عام وانتم بخير
وهنيئا لنا جميعا بهذا الانجاز في هذه
المؤسسه الراقيه
وتمنياتنا بالمزيد من التالق والابداع في
السنوات العشرين القادمه بالطبع هذا الحدث
حدث وفاه الملكه كان باهر جدا من حيث
الجماليه
الترتيبات التي اعتمدتها القصور الملكيه
هنا ولكن بالطبع كان يوم حزين لكن بنفس
الوقت كان يوم احتفال لهذه الملكه وايضا
نحاولن ابراز
يعني الترتيبات الملكيه وايضا التاريخ
للملكيه البريطانيه للمشاهد العربي كيف
تتم هذه المراسم ولاحظنا
المئات من زعماء العالم اتوا للمشاركه في
حفل تابين ق ايضا باعداد العديد من القصص
قبل وفاه الملكه لتكون جاهزه خلال خلال
تغطيه لهذا الحدث وبالطبع كان حدث يعني
مهيب تابعناه من منذ ان بدات الاخبار
بصحه الملكه الى ان تم الاعلان رسميا عن
وفاتها وحتى كان لدي تقرير خبري في ذاك
اليوم ولكن بالطبع يعني التغطيه انتقلت
مباشره لتغطيه وفاه الملكه وكان يعني يوم
لا انساه من حيث
العمل الصحفي وشاهد معادلات معدلات مشاهده
كبيره للغايه على كافه المنصات لاننا كنا
نتحدث منذ قليل على مشاهدات العربيه هذا
الحدث تحديدا تابعه الملايين عبر شاشه
العربيه مصطفى انت ايضا غطيت فتره صعبه
للغايه وهي فتره كورونا بالتاكيد هناك
ذكريات لا يعرفها احد عن عمل الصحفي في
هذه الفتره هل يمكن ان تحكي لنا بعض هذه
المواقف
اولا خلال هذه الفتره يعني كنت بعض المرات
اقول لنفسي هل انا فعلا في وسط لندن يعني
كان مثلا بالنسبه للزملاء كانوا يطلبون
منا بعض يعني اخذ بعض الفوكس بوبس يعني
تصاريح عامه الناس حول كورونا حول التعايش
مع كورونا والمشاكل التي عيشوها كنت انتظر
يعني يعني لا ابالغ ان كنت اقول نصف ساعه
45 دقيقه لمحاوله مشاهده شخص في وسط لندن
لمحاوله يعني طرح سؤال كيف يتعامل مع
الوضع وبالتالي هذا كان غريب بالنسبه لي
كما يعرف المشاهد ان لندن مزدحمه وفي
وسطها بالتحديد يعني تستطيع ان يعني تتمشى
في على الرصيف من دون ان يعني ان تصطدم
بمتلجي الاخر وبالتالي كان هذا يعني غريب
للغايه ان تكون وسط لندن يعني من دون من
دون ناس يعني يتجولون في شوارعها حتى ان
الاعلانات يعني كلها الاعلانات بدل من
الاعلانات الترويجيه للبضائع كانت هناك
اعلانات النصائح للناس لاتخاذ المزيد من
الاجراءات وتفادي يعني الالتقاء الناس
كانت هناك في حقيقه مشاكل كثيره عانى منها
الناس وايضا كنا احنا نحن صحفيون العربيه
في مكتب لندن كنا نعمل دون التوقف وخاصه
وان كانت هناك مخاوف من ان يصاب بعض بعض
الصحفيين وانا واحد منهم ممن اصيب
بكورونا خلال تغطيه لنهائي كاس امم اوروبا
بين انجلترا ويعني وايطاليا وكان يعني لم
اكن اتوقع وكنت يعني حصلت على جرعتي
اللقاح ولكن بالطبع عندما تختلط مع ناس
هكذا صعوبه لك الح صول على اجازه من العمل
المستمر زميلي مصطفى زعرور مراسل العربيه
من لندن تحياتي لك
هذه الساعه انتهت مجاهدينا على راس الساعه
المزيد من الاخبار الى اللقاء
[موسيقى]